look
[Music]
how cristian casares greets you with
his news briefing from news now in
spanish
last night the clark county school district approved a plan to
return kindergarten through
third grade students to campus as part
of a transition model to  Although they
did not define a date to
implement it, the board of directors
allowed school directors to
have small groups of students in
the classrooms that need additional help,
that will be limited and completely
voluntary for the moment, all the
students of the cis and thus will continue
with the learning  virtual
and the new mega vaccination center in
the minor cas is already in full operation
these are images from inside and yesterday
almost 1000 people were vaccinated
against the hobbit 19 during a
system exercise today eligible residents
will be able to receive the vaccine this site is
work operation  7 days a
week
and a tremendous victory, the golden
knights from Vigo began  the strong season
last night in the urine scam the team
swept the anaheim ducks with the
final score of 5 to 2 the knights will
return this saturday again against
anaheim in the scam little flour
and the owners of the las vegas' traders
buy the pegues  eses marc davis
finalized the contract with investors but
still needs approval from the
board of directors of work standing last year
the countries finished 18 to 4 they
lost the game against siero in the
final and the temperatures for this
friday promise to be very pleasant
heaven  it will be clear with the
maximum temperatures reaching almost
60 degrees the day will be sunny and it will
continue like this during the weekend i am
cristian cásseres and this is your brief
news from ignition español happy
friday
[Música]
e